[Música]
como sabrán yo soy el mago así que por
qué relación tiene la magia con los
negocios soy además de mago emprendedor
desarrollado tres negocios que se han
dedicado a la ayuda sostenible y bueno
está ahorita mismo estoy desarrollando
un proyecto de realidad virtual para
enseñar a leer unos mil negocios se
llama idea semilla en ellos pues
básicamente agarramos emprendedores y
les enseñamos cómo vender mejor su idea
ante los inversionistas entonces vi
cuando vine aquí a dar una exposición
trate de cómo mezclar estas dos cosas
que son mi pasión la magia con los
negocios así que voy a poder dar un poco
de mi experiencia en los negocios y
vamos a ponerle un toque de magia así
que necesito a un voluntario que en este
caso podría ser por favor
perfecto
bueno te voy a contar algo adelante
te voy a contar algo lo primero que te
pide un inversionista es entender cuáles
son las señales de mercado entender cuál
es la oportunidad de negocios y para eso
hay que ver muchas muchos detalles en el
mercado muchas señales y todo esto
entonces vamos a tratar de identificar
las señales que más ar
vamos a hacer algo quiero que tomes una
carta solo tocar a cualquiera solo toca
porque quiero quedar la carta quiero que
la mitad
y te voy a decir algo que dice aquí en
rojo
text ok y aquí trata las armas fuerte
aquí en rojo
perfecto si vieron que se paralizó
al momento de paralizarse es un poco de
esta sensación de miedo de esa cosa de
que esto que tengo aquí en la mano puede
ser rojo
vamos a seguir adelante vamos a seguir
adelante voy a asumir que el rojo vamos
a ver
si es rojo tiene que ser corazones o
diamantes vamos a preguntarte algo y
quiero que seas lo más sincero o tratar
de engañar no sé si esto no está por acá
pero
si ahorita te pongo a dos personas y una
de ellas te ofrece un millón de dólares
y la otra te dice que es el amor de tu
vida a quién escogerías
yo creo que la razón es porque creo que
eso sí acá y esto seguramente perfecto
muy bien
fuiste asado sincero yo creo que es una
carta de diamante de hecho fuiste
demasiado sincero lo siento por la novia
pero pero si ahora te voy a decir algo
qué tipo de chats te gustan altas
medianas bajas
y medianas
medias altas porque siento que están
mintiendo bueno vamos a hacerte una
pregunta más altas o bajas porque yo
creo que me estás metiendo así que bajas
bajas muy bien
cuando uno hace este movimiento uno
empieza a decir de que realmente te está
diciendo la verdad porque está diciendo
sí si estás mi carta es una carta baja
ponen atención 2
45 ok cuando dije 4
abriste la boca
no sé pero creo que ese es un 4 de
diamantes cierta
perfecto
y así es como uno trata de identificar
las señales de mercado trata de entender
oportunidades la siguiente pregunta que
te hace un inversionista es el producto
qué producto soluciona esa necesidad de
mercado así que necesito el apoyo de una
una chica aquí
la hora podría ser
a verla ahora aquí tengo una servilleta
quiero que te voy a contar algo tu me
compraría de esta servilleta
no quiero que la rubia esa hora y la
hagas una pelotita
listo para comprar y a esa hora
pero por qué no me vas a comprar esta
serie está arrugada
ok vamos a hacer quiero que agarrar la
servilleta ahora quiero que la guerra es
fuerte ok
te voy a preguntar algo si la servilleta
tuviera otra forma me lo compraría es
tal vez vamos a ver
qué tal esa forma
así semana con realidad
bueno adelante y eso es la segunda cuota
del mercado
básicamente a pesar de que tu producto
logre generar la solución de mercado si
no se venderían si no tiene un buen
empaque definitivamente va a ser mucho
más complicado venderlo ahora bien la
tercera cosa que un inversionista te
pide yo creo que es la más importante y
es el número mágico así que necesito
otra vez a alguien que el público que se
anima a ser un inversionista así que
vamos a agarrar por favor
adelante
justamente este yo aquí tengo un
adelante por favor tengo un cheque
fíjate y casualmente este número de
cuenta así que mira tengo un lapicero y
quiero que vayas a escribir un monto acá
ok ahora cada dólar es preferible para
mi negocio así que vamos a hacer algo
este ciudades cuenta todas las cartas
son distintas
ok así que quiero que me digas cuándo
parar yo estar viendo para el diseño
todo para ya ahí perfecto agarra tu
carta
muy bien quiero que escribas el número
de esa carta y la agregada son los tres
ceros
perfecto
muy bien la verdad es que esta fase del
inversionista es como se ponga de
acuerdo el emprendedor con el empresario
y es aquí donde vamos a tratar de ver
cómo ponernos de acuerdo a ustedes hay
una carta y yo tengo aquí un cheque ok
vamos a doblar este cheque y vamos a
hacer algo que tal vez es poco común en
esta industria quemar dinero pero vamos
a hacer algo voy a agarrar esto y vamos
a utilizar
este fuero
y no sé por qué pero al parecer
aquí dice 10
era 10.000 dólares
perfectos muchas gracias
pues sí muchas gracias de verdad pero
ahora llegamos al cuarto punto y vamos a
hacer necesito dinero de verdad alguien
tiene un billete un billete grande
si se quema de dificultades en el
negocio pero sin estados un billete que
es un poco alto
yo creo que te puede pagar esto no sé
muy bien al principio de esta
presentación
y habíamos hablado que tiene en común un
emprendedor con un mago y es que la
verdad es que ambos podemos hacer algo y
es convertir las cosas imposibles
en posibles
así que los invito a que sean
emprendedores yo me quedaré como mago
[Aplausos]